every year this is the time of year when
world leaders come to New York and speak
in the UN General Assembly last year
Ukraine's president zielinski addressed
the Gathering by video link but this
time he's expected to attend in person
President Putin facing an arrest warrant
from the international criminal court is
not coming and will be represented by
his foreign minister Sergey lavrov
the UN sees no chance of meaningful
discussions on ending the war but they
will work towards renewal of the deal
which allowed Ukraine's grain to be
exported by ship on the Black Sea Russia
pulled out of that agreement in July I
will be receiving president zelenski
I'll be receiving president erdogan I'll
be receiving Minister lavrov and
obviously this question will be on the
table of our discussions
so I'm not going to say whether I am
optimistic or pessimistic the only thing
you can be sure is that I remain
determined the other key area of
discussion this week is the sustainable
development goals being overseen by the
secretary General's Deputy in the garden
of un headquarters they've built a
special Pavilion to highlight the series
of targets the UN agreed in 2015 to help
all of humanity with the slogan no one
left behind but those 17 goals which are
marked by these doors are a very long
way from being met the UN blames the
global pandemic inflation all around the
world and conflict and of course that
brings us back to the war in Ukraine the
deputy secretary General told me the
most powerful countries of the world the
G20 which met last week in Delhi are the
ones who still need to do more with
regard to funding and reform of the
global system they absolutely need to
step up they should have done so
yesterday and we are seven years late to
stepping up to the commitments made in
Addis what we see is some movement
towards saying we will do that but I
think there are many frustrations trust
deficits around will that happen will it
not happen the UN really hopes there'll
be a Quantum Leap in the fortunes of the
sustainable development goals over the
next few days but some diplomats fear
the war in Ukraine might end up
overshadowing these efforts James Bays
Al Jazeera of the United Nations
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera